hey everybody and welcome to another hd
tutorial and in this video this is the
second part of this video series this hd
video series go ahead and watch this in
hd um we're going to be going over the
new imac so this is a 2009 second video
about the new mac refresh of desktops
here so go ahead and open up an internet
browser and we're going to look i'm
going to maximize this for you go to
www.apple.com
mac
okay if you just go to apple.com and hit
the max tab you'll get right to it and
what i'm going over today is the imac
so first of all you click on the imac
button like i just showed you
the imac basically what apple is putting
this out as is the ultimate all-in-one
desktop this is for the consumer the
average user the mac mini is a little
geared down a little bit but i love i
think the imac is my favorite mac even
though i have a mac pro
i like the imac quite a bit so they're
showing it here of course the 24 inch
model with that tiny little keyboard
i'll get to the keyboard in a second now
they have a lot of new features first of
all it comes in the 20 inch and the 24
inch the 24 inch is gorgeous by the way
second they're telling us they have
ultra fast nvidia graphics and i told
you about that in the mac mini they're
using the new nvidia graphics chip and
i'm actually going to click on the new
nvidia graphics chip just to show you
guys a performance shot if i can find it
here we go
we're going to show you guys this first
game here the nvidia geforce
this is the lowest in graphics card that
they offer and you can see there's quite
a bit of performance increases uh using
this low end graphics card in the 20
inch imac but if i go all the way up to
the 24 inch imac the highest end ati
radeon hd look at that six times the
performance increase
so that's that's a pretty good a pretty
good graphics increase plus you get that
gorgeous 24 inch screen and i think you
guys are gonna like that also you get up
to eight gigabytes of ddr3 ram which is
what i have on my laptop um which was
hard to find but
um so it's it's really slim as you can
see on the right hand side um you get
that
beautiful screen you get a terabyte of
memory if you so choose
and actually i'm going to go up to the
top here and hit buy now because then we
get the exact prices and what you get
for the price so this is the cheapest
imac that you can get the 20 inch 2.66
gigahertz intel core 2 duo
and for the 1200 you get a you get 2
gigs of ddr3 ram which is alright for a
desktop again it's an all-in-one so
you're not taking it anywhere but it's
pretty cool um
you get a 320 gig hard drive which is
nice and you get an nvidia geforce 9400m
which is the lowest and that you can get
in the mac in the imac and if i just
select it there's pretty much no options
to go any lower than that for that price
range so then
let's uh stop and then we have the 24
inch there's three versions of the 24
inch you can get ranging from 1500 to
2200 which is decent again for a desktop
it's pretty good price for an all-in-one
like the imac
we're running leopard here so what we're
going to get is um anywhere from 4 gigs
to 8 gigs of ram in fact i'll customize
one here for you with all the highest
end specs so this is the kind of pc a
lot of people will be looking into the
uh the middle end imac but here we go
i'm gonna add
to get four gigs of ddr3 ram which is a
thousand sixty six gigahertz ram you get
it's a thousand dollars extra so right
up here at the top you can see it's
gonna be be 3200 now if we do want that
ati radeon hd that's 50 bucks the
wireless mighty mouse is a 20 add-on to
the wired mighty mouse okay you get the
keyboard and again the apple keyboard
the desktop model still doesn't have a
number pad so you're going to get like
the kind that you get on a laptop you're
going to be a little bit cramped but a
lot of people again like that they love
that apple keyboard so i'm not going to
go too into that of course iwork009 you
can get ilife09
etc and the processor that you're
getting in this one for three thousand
two hundred seventy dollars is the 3.06
gigahertz intel core 2 duo so that's
pretty darn fast
so i'm going to go back to the mac tab
and go back under the imac overview
again
and obviously the 24 inch screen is
going to be really beautiful um there's
a lot of new features they say more
display for less so it's just 1500 bucks
for the lowest and 24 inch imac so a lot
of people are going to go for that that
low end 24 inch imac and now also
they're going to tell you on every
new imac you get ilifo 9 and you can get
iwork09
and um os 10 leopard so those are the
three things you'll get it all
integrated so you get all that kind of
editing software integrated when you buy
it in an imac so if we scroll down a
little bit here also obviously bootcamp
if you do feel like running windows
vista or windows 7 which i
uh can't wait for windows 7. um
obviously here's the all the new
features in ilifo 9 i'll go over that
too even though i can't i'm not
screencasting from the mac pro yet i'm
screencasting um i'm broadcasting really
from the pc for now but i'll get i'll
get screenflow and i'll start uploading
mac os 10 videos so stay tuned for that
so you can see all these things get yeah
get even more from your mac so obviously
you can use boot camp on your imac you
can get pretty decent speeds with that
3.06 gigahertz processor and if you
really want to go into the tech specs
there's actually built-in wireless and
as you can see at the bottom
um here's the resolution 1920x1200
so pretty good specs
um if you have any other questions about
the imac or a computer in general i do
tons of reviews on them so just give me
a shout out give me a subscribe to my
channel and send me a message and i'll
do a request video again this is number
two in the video series and i hope you
enjoyed this one and watch the rest of
the playlist if you feel like it if i've
put it up yet and that's basically it so
thanks for watching this one and stay
tuned for more and
hope you liked it enjoy peace